[Musique]
oui à fanons marianne prophétie de culte
chef de file oui mr belge sofina world
masturbation zurich
[ __ ]
j'en peux plus depuis ce temps elle est
tout le temps sur moi
ça fait déjà une semaine que
l'interdiction de se masturber est
entrée en vigueur et pour ne pas
succomber à la tentation les sites
internet suivants viennent d'être fermés
youporn redtube ben pub du xixe
ouais je me régale de la tabulation le
jeune homme a été surpris en train de se
masturber dans sa propre maison il sera
jugé demain pour crimes contre
l'humanité va faire beau mais j'arrête
pas de touche il habite sa mort contre
ton avis combien de fois frise pour
enlever pour tuer tous les mecs sur
terre ça freine ou des monstres ça
freine de dieu
oui voilà ça y est on m'informe que la
redoute a décidé de fermer la section
lingerie de son catalogue
c'est la mer on n'a plus qu'à crever
comme décor
ah ah
[Musique]
ça y est on peut baiser qui on veut
maintenant on n'aura plus à se branler
mec tu fous
non non non non non
oh